new york governor andrew cuomo showing
little remorse
taking zero responsibility and even
saying who cares
the governor answering questions for the
first time after his incompetence
got called out by his state's own
democratic a.g the ag releasing a
damning report showing that new york
under-reported nursing home deaths
by as much as up to 50 percent
this is a massive failure that cost 12
000 people their lives
so cuomo is obviously sorry about it
right not a chance
where this starts is
frankly a political attack
from prior federal administration hhs
everyone did the best they could
the state department of health followed
federal guidance
so if you think there was a mistake then
go talk to the federal government it's
not about
pointing fingers or blame it's that this
became a political football but who
cares 33 28
died in a hospital died in a nursing
home
they died why coveted
why did god do this
i don't know and the media is doing
their best to protect and cover up for
cuomo by giving this new nursing home
scandal
very little air time look at this chart
right here the major networks barely
touched the story yesterday
not surprising though because for months
they sucked up to this guy and told
americans he handled the pandemic
better than anybody here's just a small
sample of
the praise they heaped on him
even lifelong republicans tell me they
look at cuomo and they're like god
there's a leader i heard though that you
had a crush on our boyfriend
andrew cuomo dude i i i everyone does
right i think he's fantastic
i'm so turned on by him i'm so turned on
by the leadership
and you exposed a lot of your own
vulnerabilities a very buzzed about
topic about
you is your love life you've been
commended for your clear and your calm
leadership
we're grateful that across the country
there are responsible leaders who are
stepping up
one of them provided clear direction and
memorable powerpoints
new york's governor andrew cuomo
greg the media's got such a crush on the
guy
and they find out he's a murderer not a
good look
here's the thing why was there so much
praise
it was done not for cuomo it was done
for trump this was a very childish and
emotional response
uh based on their their loathing of
donald trump so it's like
donald trump he's not a leader but this
guy's a leader he's a great leader we
hate
you donald trump but we love him so now
that donald trump is gone
cuomo and other incompetents like him
they don't have the cover they'll still
be covered by the media
but they can't be as bad as they used to
be because there's nobody to compare
them to
finally though cnn admits that the hype
was in a headline the hype over cuomo's
role in the pandemic
uh as it was hype but they don't
actually say where the hype came from
which would be cnn obviously they just
think it like miraculously appeared
they said that his role in the pandemic
was less than
stellar which is like saying the
hindenburg's final flight was less than
stellar
it's also really really really hard to
listen to cuomo
because the way he talks just now it's
as though you're stupid
and you got to talk really slow like
you're some dumb weather lady that
seems to be his default position about
everybody and i love how he says it's
you know look to the federal government
but i don't want to point any fingers
who signed the order cuomo i think it's
you
um his callus his callousness
is so callous it has calluses
that's a good point though because when
the democrats don't have a foil
yeah they look more and more like fools
juan let me give you an analogy here
let's say bush during the iraq war he
moved the body count over from iraq over
to saudi arabia to hide the death toll
in the war zone
that's a pretty nasty thing to do this
is exactly what cuomo did
he played around with the body count and
shifted it to hide the blame for his
deadly policy
wow i don't think that's right but i
must say i agree with you that cuomo
made
mistakes your head is going to spin
okay thank you thank you uh let me just
spin around for a second and see if i
can get it on right
i will say that cuomo made tragic
mistakes i say
you know obviously if you lose a loved
one but jesse
unlike your analogy there was never any
question about the total numbers this
was all about whether someone got sick
in a nursing home died in the nursing
home or died in the hospital
so look he made a mistake he was trying
to keep the capacity
in the hospitals by telling people to go
back to nursing homes i think it was an
error and it's very clear and he is
being scolded by it
for it on the front page of american
newspapers as i read them this morning
so i don't know how the media is not
holding him responsible
i will say that i think it's also clear
and this is maybe you know to his credit
that he was
trying to deal with a very difficult
situation in new york which was hit
right at the start of this coronavirus
crisis this pandemic
he was dealing with a crisis and trying
to make the best of it
at a time when there was no national
leadership greg just said a minute ago
everyone wants to compare him to trump i
think
cuomo looks good because right from the
start
people were comparing him to trump trump
was just
not on the game trump was trump was
saying it's going to disappear
magically remember that it's going to be
gone by rewriting history
not to mention drink certain crazy
things he never said that either
he never said drinking crazy
there is no way all right there is no
way to rewrite trump's failure no
there's no way thinking about
trump's failure again why that history
again
this is also it's a flight quality over
that
if there was a reflection
we're talking about andrew cuomo i think
i think if andrew cuomo is going to
blame anybody maybe he could like give
china a little bit of the blame here the
chinese communist party but
you know he's like blaming president
trump i don't know why
cuomo again would have thanked president
trump if he was really the one who was
the problem here
and i want to look forward i mean you've
had you have a number of criminal
charges that have been brought in places
like massachusetts
against nursing home leaders for
situations that occurred
with coronavirus you have a grand jury
investigating nursing homes in new
jersey and today you have
people like republican congresswoman
elise stefanik from new york saying
there need to be subpoenas
of andrew cuomo all of his staff members
lobbyists who they were talking to
because we need to get to the bottom of
this
and find out if there is any kind of
criminal liability for this and andrew
cuomo given
the the series of facts here and his
statements and his flippant attitude
about people dying and who cares where
they died
uh you know i think people are going to
want some answers and when you have your
own attorney general who's also a
democrat it's not a republican
nailing you for cooking up the numbers
or ignoring the numbers or
reclassifying them uh you know at least
phonics says this is not just about
a nursing home scandal anymore this is
about corruption
and so and then one more thing like the
white house will not comment on this
you know they're asked about this today
by kristen fisher and
andrew cuomo was almost joe biden's
attorney general
so this idea that they are now not
commenting on this massive scandal
and the media covering it up when covet
has been like the biggest story for them
for the last year
um really there are a lot of questions
moving forward but
the criminal liability part i think is
something to watch
jillian we're we're trying to be fair to
cuomo he did get dealt a tough hand as
juan said he
i guess he did the best he could juan
said it was a mistake and that was the
right thing to say but
cuomo if you listen to him didn't even
admit it was a mistake
he said oh well if you think it's a
mistake you know talk to the trump
administration
he won't even admit that he made a
mistake and that's why
people are hammering him i watched the
whole press conference today my takeaway
was that he went on defense which as you
say jesse's really the only thing he
could do but what i took from it was
that today cuomo was trying to make the
case
that everything that has happened in new
york is essentially
like an act of god he said the reason
people in nursing homes are dying at
faster rates
than the rest of americans is because
they're older and they have
co-morbidities and then he went on to
say this is really all
just a big tragedy that's a way of
throwing up your hands and saying look
it was an act of god what could we have
done we did the best we could to answer
greg's question really quickly though
about why the media fell so hard for the
governor i think the answer is that
they started covering his press
conferences back during the height of
the pandemic and completely stopped
covering his actual policies that he was
implementing at the time it's a real
blind spot
with the media and politicians right now
in this country they start
watching their mouths what they're
saying and they stop
watching what they're doing it's
something that we saw with president
trump if somebody says things that are
outlandish
no one cares about your policies they
want to talk about your tweets and what
you said at the press conference it's
the same thing sort of
in reverse with cuomo they were enamored
by how authoritative he sounded
and how compassionate he sounded and
then the buck stopped there there was
nothing more
yes though it's the words versus deeds
yeah in reverse
there you go i don't believe
i think okay i just think it's
incredible
that in fact we the united states leads
the world and you covet deaths i mean
that's that's on trump that's not on
cuomo
and that is that's the real truth that